فصل جديد من دراما شرين عبد الوهاب منى
زكي بالوش الثاني ليله فنان العرب في موسم
الرياض وميريام فارس في اغنيه جديده لكاس
العالم اليكم الابراز في اسبوع
[موسيقى]
عن كلام قدر مني في يوم من الايام
المتوتره عادت الفنانه المصريه شيرين عبد
الوهاب الفنان حسام حبيب رسميا بحسبي ما
اعلنت في برنامج الحكايه مع الاعلامي عمرو
اديب الجمعه واتى هذا الاعلان الذي قد
يبدو صادما لجمهورها الذي تعاطف معها في
ازمتها الاخيره وربما يثير الانقسام مجددا
حولها بعد نحو عشر ايام من خروجها من
المستشفى وقالت شيرين ان تجديد عقد قرانها
على حسام حبيب تم الخميس بحضور المقربين
من الزوجين وطبعا شيرين الناس على صحتها
خلال مداخلتها الاعلاميه التي تجاهلت فيها
ما تردد مؤخرا حول ادمانها وتوجهت في
الشكر لمحمد سيد عبد الوهاب دون ان صفه
باخيها لانه عرفها على هذا المستشفى الذي
قدم لها افضل رعايه حسب ما قالت وردا على
سؤال عمرو اديب ما اذا كانت قد سامحت
شقيقها اكدت انها ستتنازل عن اي قضيه
دفعتها بحقه وذلك بعد ايام قليله على بيان
صحفي اصدره محاميه ياسر قنتوش نقلا عنها
ومن ما جاء فيه انها تعرضت لمؤامره كبيره
احد اطرافها شقيقها المدعو محمد عبد
الوهاب ونصه البيان على اتخاذ اجراءات
قانونيه بحقه مف
[موسيقى]
علي مفروده عالي
وعلى سيره الدراما اعلنت تركي ال الشيخ
رئيس الهيئه العامه للترفيه في السعوديه
في تغريده عبر حسابه الرسميه على تويتر عن
عوده الثنائي الفني السعودي ناصر القصبي
وعبد الله السدحان في جزء جديد من المسلسل
الشهير طاش ما طاش سيعرض في موسم دراما
رمضان المقبل بعد توقف المسلسل منذ عام
[موسيقى]
النجمه المصريه منى زكي الى الخشبه بعد
انقطاع الطويل في عرض بعنوان الوش الثاني
بمشاركه نخبه من نجوم الكوميديا المصريين
وتحت اداره المخرج اشرف زكي كما شارك
المستشار تركيا ال الشيخ فيديو يا جماعه
باحمد حلمي اعلن من خلاله عن مسرحيه جديده
وصفها بالعالميه من بطوله النجم المصري
يتم التحضير لها لتعرض ضمن فعاليات الموسم
اللي باعلى السهر
يا دبي
البصر وشاهد الاسبوع الماضي من موسم رياض
حفلا جماهيريا حققت تفاعلا على مواقع
التواصل في المملكه احياه سلطان الطرب
جورج وسوف وراغب علامه وادم
[موسيقى]
كما حظيت ليله الفنان العرب محمد عبده في
الرياض بمشاركه عدد من الفنانين الخليجيين
بحفاوه كبيره على مواقع التواصل
[تصفيق]
ومن ابرز ما قدم في ليله فنان العرب ديو
جمعه باحد اشهر نجوم القناع الاوبرالي في
العالم الاسباني هوسا كارلوس
واخيرا ومع اقتراب انطلاقه الحدث الرياضي
العالمي المنتظر مونديال 2022 في قطر اكدت
مصادر خاصه لسنهم بالعربيه اجتماع ميريام
فارس ومعلومه ونيكي ميناج في عمل موسيقي
من الاعمال الموسيقيه الرسميه التي تصدر
بهذه المناسبه مع الفيفا من انتاج
يونيفرسال اربك ميوزك المنتج وسيم
سالسليدي وتم تنفيذ الاغنيه في لوس انجلوس
بثلاث لغات العربيه الانجليزيه
قطر لاداء الاغنيه امام الجماهير الثامن
عشر من نوفمبر الجاري